we had a call middle of the night of a
female bleeding profusely we got to the
house and this dude answers the door and
he is a tweaker I mean this guy as high
as a kite stereotypical oh yeah [ __ ]
Radio Shack manager totally shirt off
tripping out just came back probably
collecting copper on his bike and how
did they answer the door is it always
like is there one common way that
Tweakers answered the door like what's
up no not really they don't answer the
door usually they just just see the
blinds open a little bit bam you know
you can see okay they're inside but this
guy answered the door because he needed
us okay the situation was is that he was
with his girlfriend and they were both
Hezekiah it's like four in the morning
and when we walked in she's laying on
the floor in the living room and there's
blood everywhere there's blood all over
her legs and she's holding a old nasty
t-shirt on her crotch and this this
t-shirt is pretty saturated so when we
start talking to this guy and he's you
know in his tweaker way he starts to
explain to us that they were
being intimate intimate and
um during that they had gotten the dildo
a really large
purple dildo and he had taken a coat
hanger on those old school Metals coat
hangers and he had unwounded you know
how when you like if you're doing I'll
cook it marshmallows cooking
marshmallows how do you do that well he
essentially made like that but he took
the end of that the Poke end and he
stuck it into the ends of the the dildo
and then he bent that coat hanger so it
was a handle so he was using that on his
girlfriend right so he was really he was
going yeah he was interested in there
and doing what he could yeah he was he
was making it happen trying to jump
start that couch yeah yeah so what ended
up happening was is those Pokey ends
ended up coming through the side of the
dildo so when he was doing it he was
essentially cheese grating her insides
bro I that my I feel like right now my
[ __ ] hurts oh yeah it does to this day
to this day it bothers me I don't even
have a [ __ ] right to this day it hurts
me you know but so when he described and
when he held that we said where is it
where's the item and when he went and
got it and held it up there was
literally tissue there was tissue that
was
on the thing so this was bad this is a
situation it was bad but yeah yeah yeah
that's about as bad as it gets right
yeah do you press like uh
is it like a butt do you press when it
gets too bad no who do you call when it
gets too bad you know what you end up
doing when it gets too bad what cops
have been doing they end up [ __ ]
joking about it wow they end up it's a
coping mechanism man and it and it it
just happens and I can remember in that
scenario the hardest part in that star I
had been on for quite a while and the
guy I was with had been on for quite a
while as well in that specific scenario
the hardest part for us was not to start
laughing wow you know because it was
right it was just so [ __ ] crazy it
was just so crazy standing in the living
room yeah with two Tweakers one's blink
profusely he's holding up it's got
tissue
the other problem was is that we have we
have a responsibility to render Aid yeah
you know civil liability is a big deal
when you're a cop at any given time you
can lose everything because you fail to
follow one part of your job description
rendering Aid is one of them so I
remember looking at the guy who had less
time on me side going now you know what
the [ __ ] you got to do right you got to
apply pressure man and he's got to do it
because he's younger he's younger yeah
you got well you eat less time on it
yeah less time he so I was and
that conversation looking at your buddy
and saying look at you you got to do
this man
the the difficulty in not laughing in
that situation that both of you like
your face and him look at me and going
there's no [ __ ] way there's just no
[ __ ] way I'm gonna do this dude and
you're going no you have to do this WOW
luckily we we were able to we were
having such a hard time dealing with not
laughing that it went on just long
enough that we heard sirens and it was a
fire department you know and at that
point it's like yeah this is all you
guys man some people do sex on meth for
a long time right yeah with a dildo with
a code anger oh my God methamphetamine
man [ __ ] does methamphetamine dude he
cannot stay home he cannot stay home
he's got to get to he's got to get to
work wow and it's always at night you
know that's when we get to work we would
find Tweakers they had all these
different processes of how they get
their money copper was a real big one
they love copper they would wipe out
whole housing tracks you know of their
copper but you get the occasional one
which I had one actually I think I had
two where they would go into industrial
complexes and they would go into these
massive warehouses that had those giant
metal cabinets that had the the what
like tin wires that were coming down it
that were like
20 inch in diameter you know I mean just
massive fiber optic wires and all that
no they was just like electricity there
was like a box where the main
electricity would come in and it would
all Branch off that but inside there
there'd be massive wiring and these
[ __ ] would go in there and they'd try
to cut that wiring out and it'd be live
so it would cook them dude I mean it
would just they would instantly just get
electrocuted and either a fire or
there'd be different ways that it would
that we become aware of it that we get
there but by the time you got there
these guys would be onion rings I mean
onion rings because it's been flowing
through them flowing through them and
what do they start to look like kind of
like a jit like a jerky do they start to
look like uh burnt completely totally
burnt
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one